good morning everybody and welcome to
this latest meeting of the traffic cove
19 public engagement board
can i thank you
can i thank you for
all your attendances this morning
i have apologies from michelle hill
sarah radcliffe counselor rob chilton
joanne gibson and nigel smith have any
further apologies
i don't see any thank you very much
um are there any decorations of interest
in any of today's agenda items
i don't see you there thank you
uh the minutes of the last meeting can
we please take those as read and as a
true and accurate record
thank you
uh we'll then move to item 4 but before
we turn to that and i bring in helen
collins to provide the latest update on
the kobe 19 situation in trafford
i would like to say that it's not lost
on me that the infection rating traveled
since we last met has rocketed and is
now as high as it's ever been during
this pandemic this is extremely
disappointing but i think the situation
is made difficult by the fact no one
really wants to talk about kovid 19 any
longer
there remains a sense out there that
this pandemic is over
and i cannot help feeling that central
government have somewhat abandoned our
children their parents schools and staff
within schools to the ravages of kovid
19. currently we have over 800 children
across the borough of school and nearly
100 staff
the situation in my view remains very
grave
i'm aware of the pressure this is
putting upon our public health staff who
will continue to work in what i can only
describe as very very difficult
circumstances
having said that i'll pass over to helen
for the latest update helen
thanks councillor freeman um so yeah
unfortunately our rates have increased
um
since
well over the last week really quite
sharply we are now um
we do have the highest borough in uh
rates in greater manchester
um
the boroughs below us are stockport and
thames side which is starting starting
to plateau but we are um unfortunately
looking that we're gonna continue to
increase for the next couple of days
however said that i think it's important
to note that our numbers are volatile
and and hopefully this time next week we
will be further down um the line in
terms of our rates but our rates
currently are at five thirty per hundred
thousand and that was up to the first of
october and that was 1200 cases i heard
people across trafford who tested
positive in the last seven days
the week the seven days previous to that
we're at 400 so you can see how it has
increased
i think there's a number of things that
we have to take um
away from this and one is that our rates
in our over 60s the one the group that
we are most concerned about in terms of
kovid have declined so that's one thing
we have to you know be thankful for i
think our ipc team work incredibly hard
alongside all our commissioners for our
care homes and the care home staff to
keep our
older more vulnerable people safe so
that's something that we should really
acknowledge at this case we do have
outbreaks running in a small number of
homes at the moment
and you know there's a huge amount of
work being done around that to protect
that group of staff
and residents
um obviously the big talking point the
big issue is our younger people so our
rates are the highest in our 11 to 14
year olds so predominantly our zero to
14s but it's at that group of 11 to 14
year olds where the rates have
significantly increased
i think again it's really important to
note that this isn't saying anything
that schools are not a safe place
schools are working exceptionally hard
to keep our children safe and we know
we've got a fabulous um
workforce across our schools in trafford
who are all fully you know um
capable in terms of infection control
and covered um kind of measures as well
so that's really important to note but
it is our 11 to 14 year olds where we
are seeing high increases kirsty can
talk us through when we when we go on to
the outbreak management and contact
tracing about the schools and about the
contact racing but i think things to
note are that um later today there'll be
a new greater manchester schools
framework that will be being
published this this afternoon a sign off
this evening and that is putting in a
series of different measures and that's
only for greater manchester actually so
this is we're leading the way in the
in england around this kind of framework
measures for schools
um so that will be live this afternoon
um
trafford you may be aware introduced a
different policy last week than the
national policy which is around
household contacts so our recommendation
is only for household contact so with
mom and dada poorly with covid the
children if they attending school they
um remain off school
uh and usually until day three or five
and pcr tests at that point and that
allows just for a bit more of the
incubation
and and you know more reliable
pcr result to be returned um and then if
it's negative to return into school
because what we have seen is that kind
of household
spread
and just to say on that um our analyst
tom is doing some work for us just
looking at what the spread looks like is
it adults into children in schools or is
it another way so we're just doing some
deep dives on that so just to really
just to reassure you that although our
rates are high
um the public health team and the
covered response team are doing
a huge amount of work to try to um
mitigate for these rates
when we're thinking about why our rates
are so high in this age group we do have
a couple of possible reasons obviously
you know we don't have any firm evidence
behind it but i think um some of them
are
one is around um mixing so this age
group they're 11 to 14. they're out
doing extra curriculum they're doing
clubs they're doing tutoring they're out
playing so there's that element as well
um and our community engagement team
will be working with our extracurricular
um kind of settings and our regulatory
services are as well so they're going to
make contact with our rugby clubs and
qriket clubs just to give them some
advice around
covered security we also were thinking
as a team whether it could be whether
this spread in this particular age group
could be because this time last year
bubbles were out or children weren't in
school at all so um
they weren't exposed to the virus in
that way so potentially coming back into
school um
in the current arrangements within
school is it could be you know where
they're being exposed to the virus and
picking it up and transmitting it
that way because of the mixing element
and then the other element that we think
for trafford potentially is um obviously
we're incredibly proud of our school
system and our grammar system but we do
have an awful lot of children who travel
quite a way or travel on buses and
trains and
and um and other forms of transport and
potentially that travel and that mixing
could be where we're seeing that
increased level of transmission but just
to reassure the purpose that we are as a
team working incredibly hard to
understand what is going on and we are
also reviewing all the measures that we
put in place
i i can't see anything further at this
point that we um
that we aren't doing and we are aren't
considering so there might may be um
some other things coming out later this
week that we just need agreement on um
before we introduce them but we are
doing everything we possibly can as a
team but um kirsty and ben will be able
to
give some further detail around our
testing rates which are high which again
could be one of the issues that you know
we have an awful lot of people who are
testing so therefore we're picking up
more cases and kirsty can talk us
through the outbreak management and the
school's approach as well so i think
that's everything we need to talk about
at this point in terms of an update
thank you
thank you helen um and it's greatly
reassuring to hear about the work that's
going on uh i've got a question for you
from council accordingly mike
uh thanks chair um
the element that um
strikes me looking at the map is less
about boroughs
um if you look at greater manchester as
a whole
um there's a real shift going on in in
terms of high rates
so the
the center of manchester greater
manchester has gone really really low
into the green so
and that permeates out into
um
into old trafford it's relatively low in
in terms of traffic now and it's really
in the suburbs so
does the highest rate seem to almost be
in a circle of greater manchester
amongst the suburbs um so stockport and
um
same side are part of that it's almost
continuous uh a lot a
big
area so some of the stuff you're saying
about um
schools and um traveling to
more distant schools permeates
it
it seems to coincide with that but i do
worry a little bit about thinking it in
terms of borrower terms there's
something else going on it's not traffic
per se it's
it's great to manchester suburbia really
um if you look at the greater manchester
map
um
that um there's a suffering the high and
we we've probably got the biggest chunk
of that
uh so it does permeate to us but i i
think there's something bigger going on
so council accordingly just to comment
on that so what what we've been doing
and i agree it's really interesting to
see the rates in manchester because we
would always look to mantis to be higher
i guess because of the deprivation
and so what we are doing is looking at
testing rates so we are aware that our
testing rates are higher in the south
than they are in the north so is that
around
that people that the virus isn't
presenting
which doesn't doesn't fit the picture
the pattern that we've had has it in
terms of endemic spread in the north so
we are doing some work in terms of
looking at our testing figures and then
working with our community engagement
team to ensure that people are still
going for testing
obviously you know we need to think
about why people wouldn't be going for
testing and this is something we have
discussed all the way through the
pandemic
for our um residents in the north we
know um
perhaps um you know there's issues
around attending work and being paid for
work if they're poorly things like that
so just to reassure you we are really
looking at what is going on in those
those pockets because it doesn't feel it
doesn't feel right does it hopefully it
is right but it just feels doesn't feel
like it's really reflecting the pattern
and the other thing i think we have to
say is that often where trafford follow
where trafford leads others follow
so
um
you know we might be at the top of the
table now with the highest rates but
potentially this time next week it could
be a whole different pattern in terms of
the greater manchester um spread and
rates so we are watching those very
carefully as well
thank you thanks that's uh helen i've
got a further counsel uh question from
councillor welton and then councillor
new grosh
uh
thanks mike um yeah certainly i'd very
much sympathize with what what uh
councillor freeman was saying uh uh
towards the start of the start of the
meeting it does feel like uh you know in
the sense that we've been abandoned by
central government and very much we are
we are um you know
it seems like there's almost been
permission for business as you you know
business as usual to
to resume and that's definitely the
feeling that i get around around
altering i mean it's not surprising that
our case rates are going up as a as a
consequence but what i'm hearing as well
you know locally is that there's a lot
of people who are
um you know are having sort of covid
like
um
you know in infections but they're not
they're not getting positive tests you
know and it's kind of like almost like a
flu
you know like like a kind of a flu
pandemic going going on alongside it
and you know i'm just wondering if
that's come through in the you know
that's coming through in the other
figures that you're getting and uh
um and is this is a is this a
you know is this a what you'd expect
from
people mixing again and therefore sort
of you know the flu getting going again
at this time of year um do we know if
that's definitely flu or are we you know
so counselor elton at the moment flu
isn't circulating so um uksa who are
who were phe until last friday so oxford
is the uk health security agency they do
uh flu monitoring and we get weekly um
updates is to see whether flu is
circulating in the in the population at
the moment we had no notifications that
flu is circulating however there's lots
of other bugs circulating and this is
because people have been
uh either look you know in lockdown or a
little bit more cautious and we've had
the summer months so people have been
outside and what we are seeing
across all the population is that kind
of cough and cold um general people
feeling run down um in terms of
infection prevention and control we have
we are seeing things like hand foot and
mouth and and the odd scarlet fever so
this is just a reflection that people
haven't been mixing their immune systems
might be a little bit lower and now they
are mixing
but our message would be and i'm sure
ben will reiterate this message is that
um
i suppose it is just about that routine
lfd testing if you don't have any
symptoms in your well just to make sure
that you know you are really aware of
your covered status and if you do have a
symptom of clover then do go and have a
pcr test
what we're also saying is if you're
linked to an outbreak in any way so if
you are if you're aware of um a setting
where you've been to so like a school
for example where they have um covered
activity and you're feeling slightly
unwell then what we're also recommending
is that people do go for a pcr test
books that are reviewing the case
definition or that's what we were told
um in the summer so we are just waiting
for further publications around symptoms
but yeah i think this is just a
reflection of people um not not mixing
that much and now they are mixing and
just feeling generally unwell my house
has been full of coughs and colds and
all sorts but
yeah testing routine lfd testing when
when well i think is crucial at this
point in time
thank you very much
thank you helen uh councillor new grosh
just a point on the uh differential
testing rates across uh
you're very faint julian can you speak
up can you hear me
hello okay so about the different uh
testing rates across gm
um
doesn't our positivity rate the
percentage positivity rate help
equalize that difference to give us a
clearer view
so our positivity rate at the moment is
high so it's 15. but that that's but
then that
the positivity rate is interesting in
that obviously it demonstrates the
amount of infection circulating in our
population but it also demonstrates that
those people who are going for testing
are the right people because they're you
know 15 of them are then testing
positive
i don't know if ben can talk about if
there's any analysis going on at gm
around testing and testing up take at
the moment but this is something that we
are looking at as a team at the moment
and can feed back at the next pebb
ben do you want to address that as part
of your input
yeah well i mean i if you want to just
quickly kind of adding now um that at
the moment we have seen the slightly
lower positive um positivity rate um
when it comes to other gm bowers um
they are looking into that a little bit
more um at the moment but as we say
we've noticed that our testing rate at
least the time being as of a couple days
ago while still rising whereas every
other um gm board has started to see a
fall
thank you
i've got a question now from councillor
blackburn
yeah thank you um do you have uh numbers
on
people who've been double jabbed who
have now
had positive tests
so there is a report that comes out from
oxa or phe um regularly so i can i can
find that it's it's um
it's public facing information where
they're collecting that information so
what i would say is um
that the vaccine program is incredibly
important and it has been really
successful in terms of reducing the
impact of the virus and i'm sure rebecca
will talk about that
when she covers vaccination
the outbreaks we have it had in care
homes
um
the people the residents and the staff
who have been poorly are double
vaccinated but they have not been as
unwell as they would have been if they
weren't vaccinated and i think that's a
really important message that
vaccination is still absolutely key in
tackling covid and ensuring that
everybody's double vaccinated
and
but people are still unfortunately
becoming unwell with the virus
but but i think just to add to that
council about burners our hospital
admission although our rates have
increased um uh you know for overall and
it is
predominantly driven by our younger
people our rates in our over 60s are
declining and our hospital emissions are
stabilizing and potentially looking like
they're coming down so that's a really
reassuring um kind of
variable there and i think that is very
much to do with the vaccine programme
thank you helen um any further questions
counselor welcome is that a legacy hand
you've got up
yeah it's gone
right have no further questions uh can
we move on to the next item which is
self-isolation pathfinder update cursed
him aware that this is uh finished but
would you like to just give us the
update anyway thank you
yeah it has finished so i think it's
probably good to perhaps
um take it off the agenda what we was
looking at was
um so there's an external evaluation
that's taking part what they're doing
across gm at the end of october but what
we said that we would do is do an
interim evaluation internally within
trafford and present that back to the
public engagement board to kind of show
what came out of that pathfinder so i
think just because of the the activity
that's been going on with contact trace
and we've not had chance to do that yet
but it is definitely something that
we're going to pull together in the next
couple of weeks
and on another positive note i think
the self-isolation support grant has
been extended until the end of march so
that's useful to note
um
and then also
we we're still continuing with the same
level of support when we we do know that
people need support because they've said
it to the national team that level of
what we put in place for the enhanced
pathfinder is still there so that's not
reduced off
that's very reassuring to know thank you
so i look forward to a future meeting
just bringing that one agenda item on
the evaluation in trafford that'd be
very good thank you thanks
um moving on then to the next item mass
testing ben welcome
thanks chair um so a few updates today
on on testing um first of all phone from
what helen says and we've done a large
amount of work recently within schools
so that's our response to the rising
rates we'll be carrying out additional
pcr testing at schools in trafford where
they've seen a large number of cases the
aim of doing that is basically to go and
find those who have their lives but
don't have any symptoms therefore
allowing them to self-isolate and avoid
spreading kobe to others um this has
been working really well and school's
been really really positive um in terms
of the support they've given us part of
that which has been fantastic so we're
going to continue to support in schools
with those outbreaks over the coming
weeks
um aside from that connected to schools
though um last week it was confirmed
that testing should continue until the
end of term in secondary schools at home
so if you are a parent of a secondary
school each pupil please please please
continue to test your childhood children
twice a week with electrical flow tests
um another bit i want to update on in
terms of flow tests is obviously as many
of you aware there's called two types of
lecture flow tests um and there is now
two more on the way now i'll provide
more details on those when we've got
them but i think the key thing i wanted
to highlight here was that because each
type of slightly different instructions
that's slightly different in terms of
the way that the swab works with the
tube
and we've had reports back that people
are getting um the wrong results because
they're assuming they're using the
different kits the one they are actually
using
so the key thing we're trying to
highlight here is read the instructions
you may have a different latch or flow
test than the one you're used to so have
a quick look through um most of them are
very very similar but it is worth having
having a look through because evidently
there is some confusion out there
um and then the key obviously thing i
wanted to emphasize is and as i
mentioned before we've had we've got the
currently the highest testing rates of
the boat which is really positive but
let's please keep that up so if you have
any symptoms however mild and as helen
says they are maybe looking at um
reviewing those symptoms list anyway um
but if you were to go and book a pcr
test now or it won't actually say on the
pcr website do you have a cough or a
temperature um or a lot of changing
sense of smell or taste it will just say
do you have any kind symptoms so they
are trying to be as broad as possible
with that so any symptoms whatsoever
please go and get a pcr test and
otherwise especially if you're someone
who needs to leave the house for work
please continue to test twice a week
without your flow test we know that um a
certain degree of apathy is starting to
set in now um so we're really trying to
emphasize that especially winter coming
up covered hasn't gone away and the need
especially if you are someone that is
coming to contact with other people to
test on that twice weekly basis is
really really important and we've seen
it in schools it does work it does find
people with covid and the quicker we do
that the more likely we are to go and
keep keep a hold of the valves in the
spread of that
and that's all from me chair thank you
thank you all any questions it's all for
ben
i know cindy benson thank you for that
input um
moving on then we'll go to contact
tracing outbreak management and back to
kirsty thank you kirsty
thank you chair
um so predominantly our activity has
been around schools because as helen
said that's where our case rates are
increasing
um so we're working very closely with
the schools at the minute and as helen
mentioned we've got a framework in place
that's gm wide whereas if a school is
meeting what we're calling outbreak
thresholds
and we make contact with the school and
look at a risk assessment with them
and i guess this four stages to that
risk assessment really
so if they've got five cases that have
mixed closely within attendance five
positive cases within a group that have
mixed closely and it looks like it's
evident that transmission was in within
the school or 10 percent
then at that point we'd look at whether
they are in an outbreak situation
and that's not going straight into an
outbreak meeting and putting in extreme
measures immediately first of all we
look to see if they've got the baseline
measures in place so
are they still covering those messages
about regular hand washing
um are they have they got good
ventilation within the classroom
have they got appropriate cleaning
regimes in place have they got strong
messaging around the signs and symptoms
of covid so it's going back to the
basics and making sure that they've got
all that in place as a first measure
then we'd look at additional measures
and that's where we're saying okay
you've got some cases we've seen
increased cases perhaps issue the
warning inform letter to go and advise
close contacts or maybe even a year
group to go and get a pcr test
wider communication across the um
setting just to say that there's covered
in the school and to be aware
and then we might look at considering
moving some activities um outdoors and
seeing if they can improve the
ventilation around co2 monitors so i
know schools are on a schedule of having
those delivered
and then looking at things like one-off
enhanced cleaning um whether the
positive case has been in the setting
so there's some additional measures then
we might look at enhanced measures and
suggest some of them to the school so
that could be um increased lfd testing
particularly across staff so perhaps
every day for 10 days or in high schools
um just making reinforcing that they're
doing twice weekly lfd testing we might
suggest a one-off pcr for the whole
class where we might be seeing increased
cases just within one class or one group
and we might suggest reducing mixing so
again going back to maybe staggered
entry our separate breaks
um
holding meetings remotely
reinstating face coverings in communal
areas in high schools and perhaps
limiting open days transition days and
things like that
we we put those measures in place so we
get to enhance measures and
um any measures that we do suggest are
only temporary so we don't want them in
place indefinitely we suggest 10 days
with a review to see if the cases are
increasing if cases do continue to
increase then we would
hold an outbreak meeting where it looks
at more exceptional measures
you know whole school maybe lfd testing
or a mobile testing unit within a school
and obviously there could also be
attendance restrictions as well so we've
not had any attendance restrictions
across any of our trafford schools yet
we do see that as a last resort and a
very last measure that we will put in
place
so that's kind of going a bit into a bit
of detail about that framework and our
approach to schools at the minute and it
does seem to be working
in terms of the numbers that we've got
we've got 26 schools with extra measures
in place across trafford at the minute
and as i said those are temporary
um
i guess in terms of
the
the activity of of where we're seeing
and the high cases it's in altering and
flixton and ermstone so it's in line
with
what we're seeing in terms of community
transmission
the
workplaces we've got very very low
activity across our workplaces so we are
working with 20 business settings
with 36 cases across those settings so
we're not seeing that high activity
within workplaces
um
and then
we've got our level two contact tracing
which is the cases that the t national
team haven't managed to reach and we've
now got a dedicated team in place for
doing that and we've seen um an increase
in the past two weeks where we've
managed to reach
63 percent
of cases that the national team didn't
manage to reach
um and then finally i think
in terms of key messages for our
residents and young people i think
helen's touched on some of this but it's
if you've got symptoms please have a pcr
test and self-isolate
if you've got covered in the household
stay at home for two or three days have
a pcr and then um do a daily lfd testing
have a pcr if you know that you're a
close contact so perhaps you've you you
go to a rugby team and you know that
there's a lot of covert in that rugby
team but you've not been told to go for
a pcr just go for that pcr because you
might be a close contact
and then finally
um
high schools just continue with that
twice weekly lfd testing
i think that's it from me unless you've
got uh anything else that you'd like me
to cover
thank you kirsty uh can i just say as a
chair of governors at quite a large
primary so we did have an outbreak
and the outbreak the enhanced outbreak
management's uh
issues that you've covered did work for
that school and it quickly closed it
down so you know
there is some good work going on here
and i know i mean
no one likes the idea i don't think of
of asking children of seven eight nine
to uh do a flow test on a daily basis
for ten days because it's pretty you
know it's not a pleasant experience but
i can say from where i
share a goodness it did work for that
school
any questions at all
i don't see any cursing thank you very
much for what was a very very thorough
input thank you thank you
then move on to a mass vaccination and
welcome rebecca good morning rebecca
good morning chair um and everybody else
i can confirm that i do have the cold
lurgy non-covered um symptoms and i am
testing um
helen and others so um not feeling too
great myself but it is in circulation so
um just obviously thanks to all the
public health team i know how incredibly
um hard it is at the moment and busy um
we're all kind of chipping in so so our
thanks to
i guess from what we've heard today i
just wanted to reiterate the importance
of the vaccine and
both second dose for individuals who
haven't yet had their second dose um
and
clearly now the kovid booster program
has commenced as well as the flu
programme so um i just want to give a
little bit of an update on that based on
some queries that came in uh last time
and queries that continued to come in so
at the moment and and again i think i
did mention but just to reiterate the
kovid booster vaccine has gone live for
um the priority cohorts
um as has the flu program both through
um local vaccination sites gp practices
through primary care networks and
community pharmacies too
and i've had a couple of queries um
which i just want to try and explain
today and this is in terms of the invite
for um these programs and unfortunately
some of this is a little bit confusing
um as a lot of this is nationally run
and we can't do much about it locally so
at the moment in terms of the coveted
booster particularly
um eligible cohorts will be contacted
through the national booking system um
via via text or email or sometimes by
phone and invited to book themselves to
a local vaccination site
some of these vaccination sites will be
offering flu as well but not all of them
some of them are just covered booster
and the message really would be if you
are invited please don't delay if it's
appropriate accessible and convenient
for you to
access any of those local vaccination
sites please do
if flu is not offered at that coverage
vaccination site the community
pharmacies um that you will be aware of
and that are close to you will be
offering um flu and you will be invited
by your gp as well
where the confusion is arising is that
some people are being texted through the
national booking service and invited
through their gpu practice for covidon
flu and as i say there's not much we can
do about that if you're contacted by
your gp and you've already had the
cov booster and or flu then you
obviously don't need to go to gp if
you've just had the code booster but not
flu then you can go to gp for flu but as
i say the key message really for our um
individuals is to not delay and to take
the invite that's offered to you and but
as i as i as i say i know that that's
slightly confusing because there will be
multiple access points i understand that
some people might want to wait for the
gp and if that's your preference and
you're more comfortable and it's more
accessible and appropriate then you will
be invited if you are um if you are in
that cohort so that's that's just to
kind of um confirm
the position at the moment all of the
boosters are pfizer and
we are having some feedback that there
is quite a significant reaction to
pfizer this time and a lot of people are
feeling it a little bit and i think
that's because of the time scale that's
passed since the second dose for these
priority cohorts it's um the body
reacting again but just to say as per
last time a reaction is a good sign it
means your immune system's working and
you know um it's it's reacting reacting
to the vaccine but just just to be aware
of that
so as i say just just to plea really
that people continue to access the
second dose where it's not been hard and
their booster and flu um when invited as
helen said flu's not in circulation at
the moment but we don't know what's
going to happen and it's still really
really important that individuals and
protect themselves
um
so that's that's the main message really
i just wanted to give a brief update on
the 12 to 15 year old school age program
and i i guess from what we've heard it's
it's again important to encourage where
where parents and individuals um feel
the benefit and see the benefit to um to
um take up that offer of the vaccine in
12 to 15 year old school-aged children i
don't have the most recent numbers from
this program that has commenced and i've
asked mft who are delivering that
program to provide those and as soon as
i have those available i can circulate
it but what we do know in terms of the
offers that have gone out to date there
is about a 50
uptake um in terms of consent from
parents
the team have been working on a plan for
about 60 but it's it's running at about
50 at the moment which isn't bad
actually 50 is probably a little more
than we thought obviously we'd want to
see that increase as we continue um to
work with schools and the original plan
was to offer all school-aged children
that vaccination offered before a
half-term that's pretty non-impossible
and that's not just a traffic issue
that's across yemen regionally just
because of capacity and resources and
the fact that other school vaccination
programs are also running such as flu
hpv and everything else so there's been
an agreement regionally that that offer
will extend beyond um half term
um we've had quite a lot of queries
about school aged children who have
missed the initial offer because they
weren't in school on that day there will
be a mop-up offered but we've not yet
had the details of that from nhs england
and again as soon as we've got that
detail i'll share it
and that's probably all i wanted to
update on today happy as always to take
any questions
thank you
rebecca i hope you're feeling better
soon
very honest
thanks for coming today um any questions
at all
i don't see any rebecca thank you very
much indeed for the input thank you um
so we move on then to community
engagement catherine o'connor welcome
catherine
good morning thank you welcome all right
oh hi all of you
um so an update on community engagement
uh first of all with vaccination we're
working with colleagues around ensuring
vaccine equity led by public health and
we're currently planning on focusing on
those with serious mental illness and
depression and continuing our work with
the homeless and some of the work we've
already done i think we've discussed um
on the screen with the homeless but
that's been around liaising directly
with service providers whether that's
housing
um or other support and arranging
transport to vaccination clinics
and we're also continuing to carry out
work in small geographic areas with the
lowest vaccine uptake and we're linking
in in those areas with community groups
venues trusted voices and making use of
our community champions network
and we plan on including promoting the
flu vaccination alongside our covered
vaccination messaging as part of that
joint campaign
and we're also providing ongoing support
for pop-up clinics
we may also carry out potential
engagement work to support boosters as
well so we'll be linking in with the
vaccine operations program on that
and in terms of our community champions
network we're looking at the future
remit of them and continuing to have
ongoing recruitment to boost the numbers
we may look at broadening the messages
we ask them to pass on beyond covered
and for instance there's currently the
possibility for them to work with
transport for greater manchester on
feedback on returning to the transport
network and linking in with covert there
but also other issues around
transportation
and we're also looking at our youth plan
at the moment
uh we drafted and had approved by comms
messages to get out to children's sports
club this week as helen mentioned and
those who are uncovered good practice
messages testing and setting activities
up so that children can be as safe as
possible rather than kind of um hoping
that children will follow social
distancing guidelines
and the focus on that is to keep
children and facilitators safe and to be
able to keep those activities running so
that children can keep enjoying them
together and once we've made those
contacts with those venues i will also
see how receptive they are at receiving
receiving ongoing messaging like what we
send out to the champions and the mosque
for friday prayers
and we're still supporting the young
person's action plan and that includes
supporting the pop-up vaccination
clinics that will be at the colleges and
so that's later this month on the 18th
on the 21st of october
and we're also looking at the
possibility of working with schools to
get information out to parents around
the vaccine for 12 to 15 months
uh we're also doing some planning at the
moment for winter and so we'll probably
do a similar campaign to our summer
campaign which we've basically won in
the past it will have a new strap line
along the lines of keeping well this
winter and new messaging a newcomers
plan
so we'll be looking again
at
working with public health and other
colleagues on that pulling in the key
messages
around keeping safe we also want to do
focus groups with the people of trafford
reflecting on the impact of the previous
year
their current needs or concerns and how
they're balancing keeping safe and
covered we're trying to get back to some
kind of new normal
as well as their attitudes to risk and
to others who have different levels of
comfort and concern so we'll be holding
those focus groups throughout the
different neighborhoods of trafford and
among different demographics as well
um other work that we're um carrying on
at the moment is working closely with
public health on completing
questionnaires with those who are
unvaccinated to gain deeper insights
into their reasons for that
and then to sign posts to appropriate
pathways
and in the other work that we're
currently undertaking is volunteering so
our volunteer coordinator sits within
our team
is continuing to provide a coordinated
approach to volunteering and she's
working closely with the ucfse sector
and currently has deployed volunteers to
lots of different programs including
supporting vaccination clinics testing
sites uh community engagement and other
activities working with those venues
who've also got their own and processes
for that and some of their own
volunteers they've brought along for it
it's building that community capacity
we're also co-working at the moment with
the community collective the community
hubs and thrive and volunteering pilot
with the aim to increase capacity and
resilience in the sector and then
continue that work of building strong
communities make a smoother journey into
volunteering at greater support and more
flexibility and opportunities so that
volunteering can fit in with and enrich
the other parts of people's lives
and that's it for me on the community
engagement update unless anyone's got
any questions
thank you catherine that's very very
comprehensive update are there any
questions at all please
mike it's caroline hemingway
hello caroline how are you hi i'm good
thank you well i just had the phone call
that my kids have both tested positive
um so i'm squirreled away in my office
testing furiously um mikey we just want
to make you aware of that we've um and
this other commander for the manchester
marathon on sunday
and we've had some information
intelligence that may suggest
that we've got some anti-vaccine um
protesters who are going to try and
disrupt the marathon so just to make you
aware that the race organizer are aware
i'm aware of silver commander i'm
deploying extra resources and we're
doing some intelligence scanning but if
if anybody is aware of anything uh
police can they they make us
aware
thanks for that uh
you know i'm uh
i'm just gobsmacked that didn't want to
just swap the marathon uh with that sort
of protest and and can i thank thank you
and and your officers for the policing
that's going to be taking place on
sunday
no worries
any other questions yes council
accordingly
uh thanks chair um it was just coming
back to these focuses on
people's reaction to
the pandemic and what have you um
i think probably i'm not alone in
picking up
almost unfocused anger out there from
kids and what have you we've seen
high levels of antisocial behavior and
all all the symptoms of
frustration and disengagement and i'm
i'm just wondering how we will
pick that up i'm clearly we're not going
to get these kids to focus groups
it it it's almost
it's almost going to be an anatomy to
them it's exactly what they probably
don't want to do
um
but it is out there i think and i doubt
if i'm alone in detecting that um
and i just wondered how we've how we
registered that
for what
so i come in um yeah so i think as part
of our planning for that we'll need to
look at those groups they're hard to
reach or hardly reach um in our work and
that will definitely include that kind
of disaffected um group and i think for
there you're right it'll be very hard to
directly invite people into groups like
that so i think it'll be very important
to pick up with our community partners
um anywhere by people accessing um
services for feelings like that with
schools with community groups
and just make sure we make full use of
things like our community champions
network as well so that we are capturing
those kind of sentiments even among
people who aren't likely to directly
engage and but also trying our hardest
to directly engage
where we can
catherine can i just ask have you linked
up with our youth outreach workers um
at all in in relation
yes we are linkedin but we'll continue
to have those conversations with them
and look at how we can best work
together
thank you
can i just come back
yeah i i get that i i just i have a
slight i suppose
my antenna is slightly worried that
actually what we will pick up is
lots of people complaining about that
behavior because that's the other side
of this we also have a lot of people
really complaining about young people
and what they're doing and what have you
so it's two sides of the same coin i'm
not
always sure
that the complaints are legitimate
actually sometimes it feels as though
it's being kids
and because of the pandemic we've got
lower tolerance levels
of what is normal behavior so there's a
mixture of new behaviors i mean i i
wouldn't even just
um
identify it as children i mean um
to give an example um trafford park has
always been a place for joyriding we get
a lot of that but traditionally the
traditional joyrider has a driver
and a and a person next to them who
they're trying to impress
the amount of times lately i've seen
solo joy rivals um
that's unusual that is a change of
behavior i never used to see solo joy
riders and
um i think it's almost a symptom of
something that's
really quite worrying about mental
health and all that these are adults
these are not um children um
probably sort of 20 to 30 age group but
it's definitely out there and there's a
and
trafford park just tends to be the place
they go so they it's not necessarily a
traffic park problem he's probably from
all over traffic that are coming into
there and having a go but yeah there's
there's things going on that are
rarely getting mentioned i think
thank you guys accordingly um
i take on board what you're saying and
uh and yes i think that
there are some long-term issues that
that will need to be addressed to rising
out of kovid for sure for sure
any further questions at all
i don't see any at all um
which then brings us to the any of the
businesses anyone got any of the
business at all
and i don't see any there can i just say
that the date of the next meeting is the
20th of october at 10 o'clock and
george devlin will be chairing in my
absence for that meeting thank you
george
can i close the meeting by again
thanking the work of
our public health teams our community
engagement teams who i think are working
in extremely difficult circumstances at
the moment thank you for the efforts
that you're putting in it's not going
unnoticed and hopefully within two weeks
we'll see our rates have fallen helen
hopefully um yes helen come in
i was just gonna say fingers crossed
yeah
but but thank you so much for the work
that is going on and i do think that
this meeting continues to be a very very
valuable uh um
information uh uh for
for the public who do listen in so thank
you very much indeed for your tenants
and well uh well i won't see in a
fortnight but we'll meet again in a
fortnight's time thank you very much
indeed
bye bye now thank you bye-bye